Chat and citations won't save your
vertical AI.
I'm sure many of us are building
products in what in a vertical industry.
For it be healthcare, legal, or taxes.
And usually doing so, we sell one
promise to the customers. Either we're
going to save you money or save you
cost.
And usually the pitch goes, AI agents
are here.
Uh they will do the work for you while
you sleep.
Now, primary interface that we use for
this are chat and citations. To interact
with any AI agent, right? Chats are
usually used for inputs. Uh they allow
you to be flexible. You can talk to the
agents as you please. While citations
are used usually used for outputs. They
allow you to see the results, verify the
results, and so on.
Now, I'm here to tell you that citations
and chat alone will not keep allow you
to keep the promise that you made to the
customers. Promise of, you know, saving
time and money for them.
So, who am I? I'm Atul. I'm the CTO and
co-founder at Filed. Uh I've been
fortunate enough to build products for
more than a decade now.
Um at Filed,
uh we build products for
tax professionals in the US.
We have raised more than $17 million to
do so.
And about 2 years now doing this, we
have seen massive growth in the space.
Uh just to give you an idea, last just
last month, we closed more revenue than
what we have done in the one year alone
before that. So, the growth has been
tremendous and we're very excited for
this.
Doing this entire journey for the last 2
years, we've learned quite a bit, you
know. Uh
And I think most of the learnings of
building these AI agents for the taxes
industry is essentially transferable to
any other AI product.
Now, chat is great. Like it allows us to
build fast. It allows customers to
interact with products in ways that was
previously possible. It's a
communication platform, right? Uh you
can interact with agents to do tasks,
flexible tasks that were not constrained
to the UIs that you have built.
Uh citations are also amazing. They
ground answers in truth. Other than
allowing the users to verify the
outputs, they also serve another
purpose. They allow the agents to
essentially be more accurate because now
they are forced to present the
references to their answers. Agents are
Agents perform much better with So, they
reduce hallucinations essentially.
But this is There's a key problem here,
right? Chat is synchronous. If you think
about it,
even when you're coding, you're Let's
say you're using product code
as as as long as you're typing the
request. Once the request is typed,
you're waiting for the agent to respond.
This synchronous medium does not allow
the customers to leave the platform and
go and do their work.
Similarly, citations also puts the
verification burden back into the
customer. So, think about going and
reviewing the agent's work now
one by one to ensure everything is
correct.
Especially in vertical industry space
like health care, legal, and taxes,
this becomes very crucial because now
this this adds an extra work, and
customers usually complain that no
the promise of, you know,
agents doing the work for me while I
sleep is not really kept here. Now,
before we dive in, I want to take you
through a brief history of how products
have evolved. Specifically, I think
there are three levels of abstractions,
I would call it. So,
let's imagine a bank to make it an make
it easier. Let's imagine a bank. The
banks used to have a physical presence
before. You would go to a bank branch,
you would take the money out by talking
to a employee of the bank, right?
And the point here was
the the person who's doing the task is
the employee of a particular company.
So, you as a user would go in,
you would delegate the task to an
employee, they would do the task for
you, and then, you know, come back with
the result. Be it withdrawing money or
seeing how much balance you have and so
on.
>> [snorts]
>> Now, this essentially meant the
bottleneck was the number of users
number of employees that a company had.
That's the bottleneck for creating
value, right?
Now, as time progressed, digital
transformation era came. Basically,
banks became online. You could Now, the
users can essentially open up the mobile
app or or the online portal and can make
the transaction themselves. Can actually
go and see the balance himself. This was
great.
Because now the bottleneck moved from
the number of employees a company have
to number of users that the company
have. The more users meant more value
you can generate.
Now, I think we have reached a point of
another transformation layer called
agentic delegation.
So, no longer the users are coming in
your product to use the product. I think
they're coming to delegate more and more
work to AI agents to do.
So, the point here is
um if a user [clears throat] comes to
your product and starts delegating work,
long-running work,
what would happen here is there's the
bottleneck of number of users also goes
away. So, it's no longer than amount of
value that you generate is the amount of
the number of times the user have
visited your platform because agents can
do the work while the users have gone to
sleep, you know, have delegated the task
and went off. So, the bottleneck has
shifted,
meaning you can generate more value than
ever before for your customers.
Okay, so to make it easier,
I You can think of a product You have
agentic product as a conveyor belt,
you know, and the users as the
supervisors of the conveyor belt. So,
think of it this way. The Previously, in
a conveyor belt, usually there's a
number of tasks that are happening.
There are workers who are doing the work
for you, and there's a supervisor who is
delegating the task, you know, and
monitoring how the things are going.
Similarly, now AI agents are your
workers in that conveyor belt, while,
you know, the conveyor belt and the
entire infrastructure around it is your
product. So, users can come in, uh which
who is the supervisor, can come into the
product, can start delegating tasks to
the agents.
And this would mean it give it would
give an idea of what are the tools that
you need to build in your product to
make this happen.
So that the agents can do the work and
the supervisor or the user is, you know,
pretty confident that the work is
happening.
All right. So, how do we build this
conveyor belt? So, think of this this
way. Like, when you're trying to build a
product feature, think if a user wants
to delegate a task instead of doing it
themselves in your platform, what does
what would that interface look like?
Essentially, design for delegation, not
participation.
Now, to keep it more concrete,
I think there are four key pieces when
building a agentic product.
And there are four key features or
components that you need to have so that
this conveyor belt that we're imagining
can work. So, first thing is the easiest
one. You need to find the task to
delegate.
The the tasks that are coming in the
conveyor belt are delegatable, right?
And that can generate value for users.
Second is, you need ability for users to
teach the agents
of, you know, uh the supervisor should
be able to come in teach how the work
needs to be done. And lastly, uh
there's no point of a conveyor belt
where you cannot monitor the work
yourself, right? And and of course,
intervene when something goes wrong.
Now, let's take delegation. Um so,
delegation means, you know, coming and
handing over the task to another person,
right? So, think of your users coming to
a platform and delegating a task or
handing off task to an AI agent.
So, when building for this particular
piece, you as a developer or a product
engineer
have to find tasks that your users do
that take more than a couple of hours.
So, in case of taxes, um there are like
three different tasks that we have
identified in the tax workflow, which
take more than a an hour for our users
to perform. Similarly, in your industry,
you can figure out, you know, which are
those tasks.
It's important that these tasks are
repeatable
or sort of repeatable with definitely
applicable to each of their, you know,
use cases.
And these tasks are what you use to
build what you call a long-running
background agents. This is where the
core value is, you know, because you're
taking off hours of work from your
users' hands.
Awesome. Um so, next is, you know,
uh in any industry, in any professional
industry, uh like in case of coding, for
example, everyone
every single user have their own
preferences and have have their own way
of doing a task. An example is, you
know, coding, for example, we every
single company or every single group of
developers have their own ways of
dealing with best practices and their
own conventions and practices that they
follow. So, if you create a background
agent, for example, and it does this
end-to-end task of creating a product in
case of coding, for example,
it will produce output, sure, right? It
produce It will get you most of like 80
to 90% there, but
think of it this way, like that will not
yet solve the problems of
of the user, right? As a user, you would
want it to do it the way that you do the
work. So, this is where skills come into
play. Skills already exist in the
today's world of agent development. So,
we need to ensure that your product also
has skills in place to capture where you
can teach your agents how your users do
the work. This is the last 20% of the of
the work that you need to take care of.
This is where the real value is, the
quirks of the work, you know, that
you're capturing.
In our case, in Taxes, we capture all
the all of these skills automatically.
You do not need to have like a complete
separate interface where users you go
and create skills, that won't work. In
many cases, you need to like look at the
product usage and figure out whether you
can create a skill for that particular
use case or not. So, we automatically do
in our case, and a prime example you
would have used a product called this
before. They also have like automatic
skills. So you use and it keeps on
learning as you use the product.
Now monitor. Monitor is monitoring is a
key key part right. So since agents are
long running now
the whole point is
they'll be like multiple tasks that are
running and the users need to keep track
of what is happening in this world.
So so one simple example here could be a
task list that you can do to keep track
of where the processing is for each of
those tasks. And second example here is
like
building traces in your product, you
know.
Trace how the agent did the work that it
did. They're long running tasks so there
will be multiple pieces that are moving.
So you need to trace back. So in our
case we trace back each and every value
that the AI agent produced in a
particular, you know, in the format that
the users can easily see.
This is where the trust is built. So
it's and this is where the visibility is
built so it's
it's paramount that you know, you build
this correctly. This is where most of
the complaints can be get getting
addressed if you build this right.
And lastly,
think of it this way, right? Control. So
when something requires a judgment or
when something goes wrong your platform
should inspire confidence that the users
can take back control.
This is critical because level three
product or the conveyable product that
you're building
will allow you the your customers to,
you know,
schedule a lot of tasks. But if they
don't have the confidence that, you
know, if something goes wrong they can
take them back control
then
then the users will
completely lose trust.
So
it should feel like, you know, they're
taking the users are taking the wheel,
not abandoning the car and, you know,
creating a new car, for example.
So ideally it should go like you pause
the belt, fix the problem, you start it
back up again. In our case
we could do it very simply by, you know,
pausing whenever the agent was trying to
make an assumption, we pause.
And then the users would come in just
like in Slack or any other chat
platform. They can come and tag the
agent and respond with how to deal with
that particular conflict.
Okay, some bonus points I said. Um
so, just as physical bank branches
didn't disappear when the mobile banking
arrived or you know, when the level two
arrived,
um
I don't think when the agent take layer
up to just it's an abstraction over the
last two layers
that you know, all other
mobile apps and things like that will
disappear.
Uh the point here is a user can user
will only come and delegate work they
believe that you know, they can always
take back control.
So,
so first step is you know, and having
giving that the confidence that they can
take back control, you know, when they
when something goes wrong. So, you need
to build level two features into your
product as well. That's the key point
here to build trust.
And second thing is
some actions are usually irreversible
and are dangerous actions. And in those
cases, you need to present a plan.
So, think of it like in case of bank
[clears throat] transactions, for
example, before making a bank
transaction, the plan should be there,
you know, if the certain amount of value
is going somewhere else.
Same way in our cases, when we before we
do data entry into your tax software,
which can erase their existing data, we
create a plan for them so that they can
approve the plan before they move on.
These are the key pillars that allows
customers to feel you know, control
and allows customers to feel as if
you know, if something goes wrong, they
can take back control at any point in
time.
And lastly, since we're building
products now completely differently,
like we're not building for the users to
come in and use the product, we're
building for users to come and delegate
work.
It's important that we change the way we
measure this value.
So, the most popular metric that
customers that the the products use
today are weekly active users.
Now, this is great in the in the era
where, you know, people used to come and
do the work in the platform themselves.
But, it doesn't really translate well
with agent and delegation. So, the point
is
we we have to change the way we measure.
And the I think the the appropriate
measure here is weekly active sessions.
It's I treat it as, you know, a task
that is completed by a human or an agent
even when the user is not in your
platform. So,
uh your actual aim should be the weekly
active users go down while weekly active
sessions go up, right? Because you want
your users to have enough trust in your
platform that they can come and delegate
your task as much as possible.
And those tasks are executed without a
human help as much as possible. So, the
number of sessions should go up. Weekly
active sessions should go up while
number of weekly active users in your
platform should ideally go down. It
should not be zero, of course, but
should go down.
So, what are the key takeaways? The key
takeaways are
first of all, design for delegation, not
participation. Design your products in a
way that users are coming in to your
product to delegate work, not do it
themselves.
Secondly, to do to make that possible,
you need to think of your product as a
conveyor belt. So, users are now the
supervisors, they're not operators.
They're coming here to delegate work and
monitor, you know, figure out if there
are problems and then take actions.
And finally, you need to change the way
you measure how the work is done, uh not
the time on the platform. Uh so, weekly
active sessions instead of weekly active
users.
If you keep these three in mind, you
will be able to build a very successful
uh vertically air product, I think.
All right. Uh thank you for your time.
Um and good luck out there.